[Music]
saffron [ __ ] yeah a burnoose and canoes
amazing
James I kept on waiting become the
Federative waiting for you you talk like
a poet well why shouldn't I
when I'm inspired by a perfect poet Eric
that is lovely
yes you must have one yourself I feel
like a proud knight being decorated by
his lady fair with all my sad night off
I hope so
hey what's the matter
have I said something to upset you no
pachuco can't happy I am I am heaven
Eric I have to say goodbye what you're
going away yes I must go well good night
tonight but I thought you said you were
going to stay here at least a month I
know I did something has happened to
make me awesome I said it's terrible
something I can't tell even you surely
you owe me some explanation I know I do
but I can't give away
oh I know how do I feel the same way
let me do that for you
you know this is also office strange and
mysterious like some old melodrama a
week ago we hadn't met you didn't mean a
thing to me and I didn't mean a thing to
you now you stand there filling my pipe
and serving me terribly can it be
possible the people only known each
other such a short time just seven days
it seems much longer
yes but much has happened
we got a perfectly glorious time and
until ten minutes ago I was possibly the
happiest man in the whole world but now
raylene three more important birthday to
state
what does it say
oh I forgot you you don't know German
Germany has declared war on Russia Oh
may I go brain I can be boy food you
because boys a ghastly thing God knows
what this may lead you
good thinking or going
you'll be safer in London you're not
going away because because of someone
else oh no you mustn't think that
there's no one else there couldn't Ellen
will you say goodbye to me
quite year because I want my last
thought will be here in this garden well
we've been so happy together last time
you don't mean that this is really
goodbye no not goodbye
just I'll be the day
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
good morning ah good morning miss Goren
um as usual just to show you that I
don't need much more prompting we shall
see
[Applause]
I hope your traffic in your lesson
anyway yesterday I think I shall be is
becoming second thank you
right you are now no longer chain
Gershon violin coaches for this
major-general Sir George pans okay
Phoebe how long has he been in command
of the border two years for this lady
Crandall how did you first meet lady
crap
our mothers were friends have you seen
my table really Karen over the last few
years not since I was 14 and your family
kept in touch with lady channel my
sister Pauline writes to her all the
time and it was through her that Lady
Clara invited you to visit aboard oh yes
what was the name of your governess for
lady candle kneeling and what is your
name
and after who were you named my name is
ben and poachy I was named after my aunt
Ellen where have you been living the
last three years in Paris
studying the violin anywhere else no
that's splendid
miss one eight nine three all right
number one is nicely I think you passed
anywhere and I need tests i bill because
I see little I really am Ellen for K we
have to be careful because I feel this
house is being water can I do all the
plans again I don't think it's necessary
I have a picture of every room in my
head
you'd better take this you never know
when you may need it you have all your
instructions yes but are you sure
there's no chance for the actual
misquote you know whatever we have taken
good care of that and here also how am i
oh I hope miss Gershon still plays the
violin as well as ever and where's the
luggage there love it's at your hotel
[Applause]
of course I don't have to tell you to be
careful
jeepers waters not exactly a pleasant
spot for people in our line of endeavor
I'll be killed
I want to impress upon you that this is
not only an unusually important lesson
but an unusually dangerous and are no
circumstances whatsoever must you reveal
your identity except by the residues of
your number remember you're acting
absolutely alone without assistance in
enemy country your sex cannot say male
or female you are a spy I understand sir
there's no more to be said except Oh
Peter then all right I'll see you then
if benjin also touch Beatie
German is a perfect man
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so your name is Buckley now you
certainly have a great deal of courage
to come back here at this time I I don't
know what you mean you know exactly what
I mean okay sudden the guard sergeant of
the guard two men quick march
Oh
not a very pleasant thing to say on
landing I'm afraid here we didn't I'm
sorry but it's war
miss Katja let's go Jake may I ask why
you are in Gibraltar I've come to visit
lady Crandall I beg your father if you
don't mind waiting a minute or two I'd
see the lady Crandall knows you're here
at a time you see in order to go through
the fortifications one has to have an
escort I understand
and how long must I wait possibly 10 or
15 minutes miss Katya if you'd rather
wait in that hotel across the street to
Paris I'll send the car over there boy
take this lady's bags across the street
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
my bad
[Applause]
[Applause]
good morning members Oh imma make
Georgia money I am at your service
I make Spanish I'm just waiting then Oh
while you are waiting permit me to offer
you the hospitality of my private office
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
may I thank
[Applause]
I say Mademoiselle is a musician violins
are my hobby will you permit me to look
at yours
Oh
[Applause]
and that I should like to play it
I see you have my favorite malady that
dog do you know it - not very many
people do these days there's not so old
it was written in 1889 no 1893 id2q one
date 93 I'm glad you've come from and
reported our boobs and you are one eight
eight nine but tell me how did you ever
recognize I was told to look out for a
pretty lady carrying a violin case mark
DC everything is working sorry for 12
years I've served the film Strasser
Constantinople in London here on the
rock but never before has there been
such an opportunity
well let's get down to business
good
do you have studies any plans of the
fortification of the rock no I remember
them quite well you see I was here seven
years ago
[Applause]
but here are the plans that will give
you the details you need study these
tonight and burn them before you sleep
and be careful yes you know room B yes I
remember that's next to the governor's
office right in that room there's a safe
- rich only to have the combination the
staff major and myself
[Applause]
there it is the dual combination don't
fool yourself there are two sentries on
duty by day and one by night watching
that moon only using the safe is not it
is charged with electricity and will
kill anyone anyone who doesn't know the
right way to touch it and how am I to
learn the right way let me show you
there are three handles on the panels on
the bouquet the two on the right you
turn so on the bookcase on the wall or
slide away exposing the safe no on this
safe there are two dials thank you but
if you stand in the natural position to
open safe and touch those two dials you
will not only give the alarm you'll
electrocute yourself
charming ideas but if you stand 16
inches back from the safe so and
or you can wake the combination without
danger oh you're right
and in the event that you all then
in the drawer marked D there is a team
tomorrow morning early you must get it
out for at five minutes to five number
54 will come to you for it and who is
number 54 that none of us know but he
will meet you there
and make himself known to you until then
you must work alone
thank pardon sir but there's an officer
here and officer yester with a car from
his cart hey mister courtier yes sir Oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Oh miss Corday I presume yes I am it's
gorgeous
well I'm the generals aide you know I've
been sent down to Scott you to this
porters how did you captain
really I please forgive me I haven't
introduced myself I'm I'm I'm Lipton
Archibald and sediment tumbler royal
gala smart oh yeah this is no fitting
they don't you bother with it
most of my friends and find a lot of
people really are my friends call me
aren't you all right thank you
shall we go
Chiang Mai guess I figured your pain how
many different but I suppose you
surprised everybody you know as a child
you weren't particularly good-looking
but now you developed into a totally
beautiful
oh oh rather lady Crandall yet most
extraordinary beautiful but so that
means I've got to go on report ice first
I don't if I were you RC and will make
you any happier I may tell your fellow
officers for me that okay it's great
eh oh really then extend life I bet you
behave separately I'm so glad you know
I've seen you again miss Corday
yes by RG I beg your pardon
oh good boy yes of course
goodbye he's a nice boy but still aboard
oh but you let me sit down I'm so glad
you brought this oh yes I know my
favorite one
let's watch it is owned by Fred Oh is
lending happy yes baby together
any baby feels right over and I saw you
standing at the door I thought I didn't
expect to be I suppose door chain
I don't think you look at game
but tell me how it did George what's the
George is very well and he's very
worried
I suppose it is a big responsibility
being in command Gibraltar particularly
now but it isn't only that he's fed
the intelligence Department is notified
him to take every precaution but surely
it's impossible to aspire to come here
to blonde that's just it it isn't
impossible by only this morning they
caught a man at the barrier did they
think he was a spy think it my dear they
knew it so George is just arranging for
his trial
[Applause]
mirtha thank goodness it over yes
there's nothing I hate more than a
Kaufman I think we should be locked up
one come in captain would Oh sir the
Royal Engineers with us in Genoa sir yes
sir that's the new sapper to assist me
oh yes
show him in
major-general Crandall yes so you're
good huh say yes glad to have you with
us full house
thank you this is Peter bishop how'd you
do
how are you would not have you brought
your movement orders hey what not
particularly done I came through space
trans have brought it in a term on the
line of chaotic that is its lack of
pitch off the dock you know everybody
that is affected to being a spy
our intelligence Department is
suspicious - they think the William
Strasser has agents everywhere in the
orderly told me that you caught a spy
trying to sit through this morning we
did you just come from a court-martial
now caught red-handed
poor devils be shot tomorrow morning I
couldn't about Marjorie Platteville our
intelligence department thought he might
have accomplices on the rock and the
operative it's like if you betray the
master spy of course he denied
everything
look Sam there's somebody for you to
learn
it's the surface job to keep it with
my joggins catheter how'd you do it a
lot about this room you'll have to learn
the duplicate controls with all the
Harbor defenses which are well sealed of
course you'll soon learn all about our
little tricks except the combination of
that safe that's secret be a convenient
method of suicide I feel a deep trance
having some friends to teach oh thank
you very much done but this map gee how
do I gotta change into uniforms oh well
that's all right bye boy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what oh how do you do captain
how do you do lady Crandall arrived at a
very appropriate time
do you know anyone here no I'm afraid I
don't
may I inquire who was playing so
delightfully Oh Ellen Gautier and she's
just as beautiful as her play would you
care to meet her
I would like to lndia
[Applause]
ah you know each other plan again you do
know somebody bit well I certainly
didn't expect to find misko I didn't
expect to find Julia more well isn't it
[ __ ] okay Kevin Oh
let's go get me
but you didn't tell me you were coming
here hi
I didn't get a chance to tell you
anything you were the one who did all
the telling you told me you were going
to London let us go out on the back
right right goodbye
I beg your pardon sir the mr capa
insists on seeing mr. Chappel he said
she was with you in india that kappa
Sherman very well and
you stands out
[Applause]
bro you haven't forgotten that service I
did for you in India of course you want
paid for it weren't you yeah but I've
been hearing about you since then hasn't
been altogether a comfort of interest I
hope it doesn't true I did go to pieces
a bit for a while I was sick I've been
running him pretty hard
not the past two years but they can't
keep it all much longer I'm going soon
so I'm sure you wanted to see me about
yeah I'm in England you know that I may
be down and out and my friends may not
want to know me when we meet but I'm
English
and I am alone yes yes I'm sure I've no
doubt about that I just wanted you to
keep that in mind general while I talk
[Applause]
little crate make a pin burn
three
no you haven't forgotten how he lived in
Burma a couple of years mingling with
the English until someone suddenly found
out that his real name was Krantz and
that he was a mighty and healthy chapter
hub about Shirley Jen yes I remember him
now sander with Alice broke I'm going to
speak about birth I'm sorry general but
you thought she was all right until a
couple of Secret Service men walk into
lady Langdon's drawing-room and took her
away from come what are you driving at
hop with us you couldn't let me have a
little drink good job one plate of
decent scotch well it'll help you to
talk more intelligent
[Applause]
just come from the Paris hotel gym it
was a girl there today had a private
concept with help she said her name was
coach well what of it
remember crane general remember Alice
Broughton
what do you mean what do I mean I mean
that they scale because it's a cookies
and cookie at all Jesus pie what Bobby
show this man out so help me general I'm
telling you the truth I know the real
Ellen coach if I knew her in tights
I can't through what I say the wildest
dreams of the velum stars are come true
they've got a girl here right in your
quarters general I don't believe it's
true all the same I'm warning you that's
all I can
[Applause]
now
[Applause]
today
[Applause]
goodbye Kappa
[Applause]
goodbye sir
[Applause]
I told you once I couldn't give you an
exhalation and I still can
Jane it's different now you mustn't call
me Jane my name is Ellen Koch a oh now I
understand when I met you in Germany you
thought perhaps it would be a nice
little adventure
I don't mentok adventure with a stranger
so you gave me an assumed name and then
left you needn't have done that Jane you
could have been honest with me
I was and why did you tell me your name
was Jane Gershon I can't tell you
anything but now you say your name is
good heavens
you don't mean to tell me that cookie
isn't a zoomed-in no I am Ellen Croce do
you realize what you're doing you know
what could happen to you only this
morning they picked up a suspect the
barrier I know he was right in front of
me when he was arrested what happened
what did they do if you're interested in
knowing he's to be shot first thing
tomorrow morning
oh this is war Jane when that poor devil
tried to get through here this morning
he didn't know that his own side had
sold him out it's horrible yes it is
horrible once I had to attend the
execution of a spy he didn't die like a
hero hello
he died like a dog but don't you think
after all I hero was one who knowing he
may die a dog's death still carried on
[Applause]
thank you fought very Crandall Center
comes to capsule would request the
pleasure of his company at dinner
thank you I'd be delighted
you look at as a junior officer weren't
you I was
but I want you to come over to dinner
tonight yes sir but this charters mind
never mind that but the new eight do it
this is even more important I just heard
a ridiculous story nevertheless I can't
afford to ignore it what is it
it's preposterous of course but I've
just been told with our guest
lady Crandall spreading this little
spike you don't say
was it a reliable person who told you
sir not at all I still have to
investigate I want you to help me
cross-examine I care about that shall we
bring her in here oh no nothing official
you just do it in a more casual fashion
what do you remember about 1907
[Applause]
Reagan was governor Reagan
then she must remember Mike
that's a school
what do you mean
you have a positive power hanging in
your dreams no one who ever knew work
could failed to recognize it let's try
her on lady evening blend that's a
splendid idea come on over tonight how'd
we do
so miss why don't you like Gibraltar
[Applause]
this is the quietest place imaginable it
used to be an old monastery it seems
funny to think of a lot of old fat
months sitting around toasting their
toes very fireplace yes it would be fun
but as a matter of fact that fireplace
has only been built five years by lady
Crandall told mr. Oh
how do you doing ology try to tell us oh
I know our chicken lutely hot more
easier than any boy I've ever known
oh he's in good company then is that
sarcasm Oh admiration oh you know I've
often told Archie it's a good thing lady
even is here now well lady you've been
triggered yes the David Quiggins wife of
course she was a terrible flirt that's a
portrait here can't you tell
oh yeah yeah she has that computer look
in her eye
[Applause]
I hope you're enjoying yourself Briscoe
t8o having a splendid time sir I suppose
you think out of that yes have you come
and died with us
Oh believe me lady Crandall it's a
pleasure that I'd miss but you know how
I'm changed my death I guess is carrying
the whole way to the rock on your show I
do hope to come more often
now that I have Woodhouse to divide the
wait copy Allah cure
well the cure if I may won't you join up
with us they thanked amenity I'm
surprised you don't remember mr. Fuji a
bishop I'm afraid he doesn't remember
the lanky young stood at once with me
he's been a Tennyson and several
students have eyes only for the
Colonel's life
I suppose the old rock looks familiar to
you me okay seven years is a long time
let me see you were here so when Reagan
was governor yes yes for today [ __ ]
friggin did you know him no no I think
that oh he's a caulking chef yes big
blast rings orders a seller doesn't do
that well known as I remember sedated to
the short Batman
of course anyone is my mistake stupid of
me on I must have been confusing him
with someone else
they've now remember to David so well
because I've had teeth the place seemed
very much the same after seven years do
you notice any change
[Applause]
doesn't mean I think job you have a good
memory with stretch it must be built
then it's sometimes very important then
you were you must remember lady Cragen
how could i seven years or seven no one
could ever forget her
so it was the generals wife and that's
good
but she was a wonderful woman yes indeed
do you think her picture is like her
miss cookie
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's perfect simply perfect
I always thought the hair and the eye
what
tell me does it still make your heart
beat faster me
well Arrieta - good like this Python
I think lady even the strictest sense of
addition
just sing one small bullet capturing it
hi again
I always thought your ultimate
impregnable and it is to the ordinary
invader
look for June
[ __ ] dozens of dissolved rain in London
[Applause]
that's the british mediterranean
squadron my dear wonderful wonderful
there's a part of the pride of England
gives one quite a thrill doesn't it yes
it probably thrilled friends the enemy
in a rather different way
Jeanette all excuse me quite a homesick
tug to see the grim old out
I haven't been to be home to the little
island in four years it seems as though
the old roster to have quietly waiting
that's the kind of girl to do it charlie
yes sir
don't find out the latest reports on the
fleet what time they were ready to say
it
yes
well Bishop and what do you think of
biscotti
[Applause]
well that's all right he knew her before
and is just as well as he should know
what we suspected even though I'm now
convinced that I was wrong I'm not so
sure but she do about the fireplace she
recognized baby Prince portraits but the
troubles are 10 why shouldn't a person
came to be with the stories your friends
must miss Katya at all the German spy
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Oh Jane I'm glad I thought I wanted you
to explain I made no attempt to conceal
the back Jane if I was it was because I
had a definite reason that's it
I believe you I'm willing to take your
word that's because I care I want you to
care for me I am changing but promise me
this one thing you don't know you can't
possibly know the risk you're running I
wouldn't ask you in defiance of attack
that had none but here you are running a
terrible risk if anything should happen
wife you must promise to do it I asked
what is it leave the rough that buster
you can buy the next Boat well I
so that's your answer please I
understand why what is dude
eh official request to even meet you
stay in need be ready by loud telephone
the run system came
goodnight miss cookie
mother he what what what what did you
wanted me to do tonight okay here's a
chart to the hovering straight this is
the fan showing the distribution please
check them and send them out to me but
it's very important
no lady ordered his father's
[Applause]
all right then
[Applause]
that is a beautiful sight each one is a
little world in itself tell me why are
the lights blinking off for sending
messages did I send messages all the
time
Jane you didn't come in here to ask
question you said you had something
important to tell me
I hope you think it's important well
what is it
I came to tell you I love Jane
it isn't easy for me to tell you this
Erik
that's why lamb I tried in front of him
but I couldn't bear you leave me like I
just have to do darling
[Applause]
captain Woodhouse miss got it what's the
meaning of this
how did you get her here I let her in
sir I it was my fault sir George I'm hit
upon coming here so because you insisted
captain Woodhouse broke the rules you
must be a very eloquent persuader
biscotti and as for you Woodhouse this
is hardly an auspicious beginning chummy
yes sir will you please escort miss
Katya to her quarters with pleasure and
when you go knock this room yes
[Applause]
captain Woodhouse I wish to talk to you
[Applause]
I say that the old gentleman suddenly
was avoiding in suppose he's going to be
there to deal with captain will help
well I I don't know how severe he'll be
but I would like to be in Woodhouse's
boots for the next half hour although I
I wouldn't mind it being in Boots for
the last half hour you know I don't
blame what house I'd let you go anywhere
you want just like a prisoner and you oh
my god taking me to myself yes isn't it
jolly why well I I've never had you to
myself for five minutes yet some bounder
always comes barging in now that you're
in my official chart I've got to a load
of love but only been here to my room oh
that's all right
he certainly ordered me to take you to
your room but it didn't say how long I
was to take taking you Oh mommy we might
to sort of delay down the way we might
what did it any mortar rally rod oh I
know a lovely place here we might listen
to the nightingales sing other
nightingales on Gibraltar
no but there are monkeys don't you
remember
[Applause]
we can watch the beach yes rather pretty
in this it's more than fitting it's it's
hard to think of the Dean fighting
machine
they look so peaceful now somehow
they're blinking like to remind me of
fireflies dance yes I like watching the
blinking light - let's sit down I'd love
to see them pull a string tonight when
they say about to see information it
must be beautiful
I'd like to stay up all night like this
myself
topping idea I'll serve all night with
you yes they sail tomorrow at dawn yes
six o'clock the dawn round here fight
the earth sure do you know what makes
tonight especially beautiful for me no I
feel very much honored that I should be
so important in the life of left hand of
the Honorable Archibald Plantagenet
Chumley oh it's gorgeous
Alice I'm in heaven Ellen please don't
wreck you know I'm ripped listen sir yes
you know ever since you arrived here
I've been walking about in a daze
you know you possibly the most blue eyes
I've ever seen and I just adore blue
eyes yes I love
would you mind going away old man thanks
you know ever since you came here I've
been walking about all goofy you know
you possibly the bluest eyes I've ever
seen yes
I adore blue eyes and yours are the
fluid in the whole wide world darling
now now Archie oh but Helen you're so
gorgeous what if the gorge should be now
hold bother Sir George won't you take
baby Franz was waiting for you really
why didn't you tell me you're so
fascinating I almost forgot oh there you
are laughing at me again come on
well I I brought you back safely much as
I regret it
good night thanks good night
[Applause]
oh I searched
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Oh
so did you
Eric I came here expecting to find
someone but I hope it wouldn't be you
why did you expect to find some
[Applause]
you do this system play as you played
that tune you know the one written in
1893 you he will evolve in surely you
can't be number 54 yes I am
ladies please get away from here big boy
your seat I'll put the key back and no
one will ever suspect
Oh Jane I tried before to get you to go
and now I'd thank you again to give up
this don't waste time
please hurry for my sake but your see
I'd always heard that you rule number
one 893 for the most spirit and look
this woman in the service Oh Eric please
come I have told you I love you if you
love me you think I could leave you here
the band the brunt of this alone No
Eric you can do this
come here dude
you couldn't send those sleeping men to
their death trap
[Applause]
now you're talking like the woman I love
not like the ruthless one 893 but why
why are you reading for these day I'm
not pleading for them but for you
why because I don't
I love you more than my duty more than
my life and there's only one end for the
man who does this
against the wide James
[Applause]
what am i doing
who can realize that what they're asking
me to do is impossible but you can't go
on with this Eric let's all do horrible
whatever lives of 0.12 me if I pay the
Miss it means my life I'm not like Bell
came sold us out and for woman to God
will soon be here to change centers you
go to your room at once let me get this
thing done
I'm not going to let you do it here I
love you sobs you speak of love you were
treated of a fatherland love of such a
woman issue is an insult so this is a
big living then you will see another
side of the woman you've tricked you
said one eight nine three was fearless
Andrew I am give me back that P i okay
[Applause]
Jane you couldn't do that
but you wouldn't force me but if you do
you leave me only one alternative to
raise the alarm
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
firing squad Pavelka
[Applause]
[Applause]
you'll see havoc that's what will happen
to you instead the man I loved
couldn't die like that I couldn't let
you feel that I had died like you
[Applause]
do you know what you're doing you
realize that you're sending me to my
death
[Applause]
auf wiedersehen
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm buddy
[Applause]
I have been listening to you and that
Weekly what she knew both you made a
pitiful creature out of a brave man and
the useful one you sent him through his
death and as he died
so will you die
[Applause]
but first you will see the menu ticket I
used to ask it put it like
torture
and round
[Applause]
[Applause]
but you can't be no I am number 50 for
you the Georgia faithful servant sure I
said George is faithful Beth waited 10
years for this you were sent to help me
and you killed him for nothing
[Applause]
I don't need to tell you what seed this
one is the master control to the mines
which will destroy the fleet and bring
death to America and your death also
your death your hand will be found in
the control and I am Artie but I shot a
spy cool eh
thirty seconds over relays will be set
for the mines under the fleet
[Applause]
[Applause]
Oh what
general cranly your servant was an
enemy's spy
I want you to understand that no matter
what mr. chairman have done you can now
thank her for the safety of the fleet
[Applause]
George let's go into Eric's captain
Woodhouse space please don't be too hard
but don't you know he showed the
intelligent Department certainly have a
peculiar way of working they didn't let
me know who you were until this morning
I don't understand sir you're both
working for the same Falls Miss Jane
Gustin of the British Secret Service
allow me to present captain Woodhouse of
the intelligence department but Eric why
did you let me suffer him but dear your
life was endangered every minute I saw
his pistol behind the curtain
there was nothing else that I could do
jane darling
that's so much to say to you
[Applause]
[Music]